the reason we were so excited to be
involved with this project and helped
spearhead it was that our mission is to
promote and teach the art of special
effects and character creation to teach
people how to create living breathing
real characters that you can put on film
that you can put on stage that you can
put in your honoured house that you can
take to comic-con real stuff because you
can't touch pixels and you can't take
them to comic-con and we believe that
preserving the crafts that allows you to
do that is critically important this
robot is proof you don't have to rely on
a team of people that are in a closed
box looking their computer screens to
recreate reality because that is reality
so you don't have to worry about
lighting it gets lit you don't have to
worry about you know how it's going to
look from the other side just just turn
to the other side you can plan all you
want but once it's there in front of you
you'll find moments and angles that are
just unlike anything that you could have
thought about if something is actually
moving and making noises and interacting
with them I think it's going to blow the
mind it'll expose them to what we can do
practically and hopefully you know
everybody sees that we can
cool things come to life it's right
there in front of camera you know this
is way different than just looking at
the screen monitor there's actually
standing in front of you talking to you
and walking toward you hopefully they
can look at it ago do that and hopefully
that will inspire them because you know
when you see this thing and it's walking
down as arms are flying around every
place I I want to be there you don't
really know us so you made something and
then you learn from there and you just
keep trying to get better for the young
generation that you just don't give up
and just try hard I'm still gonna do so
if I do certain technique but that's of
my ability and somebody sees how I do it
and then takes it a step further that I
don't think of or anything like that and
makes it better than that's what it's
all about then I can make improvements
on that improvement I think you're gonna
see fans taking it to the next level of
cosplay I think it's I can't wait to see
it because I think it's just going to
drive everyone's just going to start
driving it's this engagement of here
look what we did I think it's just going
to keep evolving but what we love is is
the arc of what we do and that goes all
the way from you know the sketch to the
mechanics to the electronics all the way
to the performance at the end it's all
art form and you bring in your combined
experience and this is just another
venue where you can say you can be an
artist you can you can bring what you
love to an audience
it's like find your audience find your
voice our voice happens to be a nine and
a half foot tall robot with four arms
jump
create art create characters create
robots create whatever it is that makes
your heart sing and start today what are
you waiting for
Oh